and now they listen to me they
don't listen to me
now yes
although thanks to all
hello it's me and thanks for being there
we are waiting steve so
only 12 more moments thanks
and in the meantime please for all
those who are write in the chat from
where they are transmitting
hello steve
very good
very good thank you welcome
we have many viewers here
to welcome back in the chat well
ok I'm salvi and today I'm
broadcasting from arizona in the
united states so there's a lot of sun and it's very
nice that I just got here last night I'm
here  for a few months with my friends and today
we are lucky enough to receive a
presentation from steve coleman who
was broadcasting from vancouver and if
certain tweets are
good and for those who don't know
this he is a polyglot he speaks 19 languages
r less and they are on trial in  the
process of learning his language number
20 which is Arabic
today he is going to give us a little
presentation about his process in
learning the ar  abe and obviously not
all of you are learning the tree
but you can still apply the
steve way lessons to any
language that they you guys are
studying and after that we're going to
take your questions so if you want to
use the chat to ask questions
after  the presentation of steve and the
back answered
and well received in rap thank you thank you
very much pleasure to be here unfortunately
here in main kruger it is raining you
can see a little I got here it is
not arizona there is not much sun although yesterday was
a very very splendid day with a lot
a lot of sun and played golf with my wife
well let's talk about
language learning and especially not because I'm
learning Arabic but I know that
most of you are learning
other languages be English French Japan
se Chinese whatever is good for  me
e this month is good it's the third month of
the challenge for me 20 days
in Arabic
so I'm focusing on
learningj  e from Arabic that is why I have
some goals and I am going to explain
how I work with those goals that
direct my efforts in
learning Arabic
and I am going to show some screenshots to
illustrate what I am doing
you must say that for me the goal is
Language learning is above
all understanding, this being able to understand,
understanding what others are saying
is more important to
me than being able to speak, because finally,
if we have a good level of
understanding,
the ability to speak and express ourselves
will  come
then, in order to understand
we have to listen a lot, read a lot,
as I always say, and we need a very high
level of vocabulary, a
lot of words and phrases,
the goals we have for the link are focused
on this goal of accumulating words and I,
because good at the apprentice  nick's
path in learning Arabic was
the following I started with the mini
stories that we have where there is a lot of
repetition because at first  start
at start Arabic for me is
noise
and I don't understand anything
in writing and now you see it's more
difficult than writing so we
're used to it with
Latin Roman writing then it will be
difficult but with a lot of repetition
listening to a  or again the same
story not right away but I would be 1 2
3 4 5 and then one night I haven't
listened to those stories 40 times and
finally the structure of the language
between my head and many words and
especially verbs enter my head and
this  it gives a base
because there comes a time when those
stories are too boring and I
can't continue to listen to those same
stories right now I'm
looking for more interesting things for me in Arabic
because it proves there are fewer resources than for
example in English for English and without
limits without limits
internet resources but the problem
is a little more difficult but I have
found the podcast of the aljub
sierra algeciras al jazeera of qatar
s  about politics in the middle
east for me it is very interesting but
listening I don't understand much that's why
I need the transcript
happily there
are automatic transcription services now that are very very
good very precise precise also the
description is like 90%
perfect before I had to  pay a
person to do the transcription which
is very expensive and I cannot share this
with the other members of the link because
I do not have the rights although I have
asked permission to share this with
delight but he does not answer me at night
so I cannot share it so very
expensive but with automatic transcription
this is much better you
can do it for 10 dollars a month I have
about 12 hours of transcription
and then it's very good there I'm going to
show how it works but
with transcription there is what is called
in English  times steps well with this I
can import the transcript of a
25 minute podcast on politics
which for me is very difficult  il but I can I
can study this transcript
inside the link one a sentence at
a time a portion of content at a time and with
the times temp the narration in the work
of the podcast will be
as it is said synchronized with the
piece of text that I am  studying
this is very very comfortable
but then my activity now
after this period of six months listening
many many times to the mini-stories
now I am solid working the
podcasts which is authentic
content interesting but difficult content but
using the automatic transcription
with the time stands so I  I do
in sentence mode how we say in
English
an expression an expression sentences
now now an action well in French it
is an expression in Spanish
so I can study the content
small sentences with the
original sound and look for words that I
don't know save the words as we do
to the link good my goal now
returning to this question of goal
my goal during  these three months it will
reach a level of known words
of 20 thousand ok I started with a level of 14,000
and I think that with a level of 20,000 it
will be easier to understand
the podcasts now
now I am going to show that I am going to share
my screen it is possible
and yes good  let's see this very technical
I'm an old man I'm not very good technique
[Music] to
be screen
green screen to be broadcast
efe
perfect
and we're going to see that we go to the link
you can see it without life
and we also have your vote
good this is the  night
here because we live by the sea and
when there is a shop in ezeiza
[Music]
like the sunset
we establish if that's right there is
very cold water now but in the summer you
can bathe although down here we have
two symbols of the link
the symbol that  it has 376 this is the
new link that I am testing as a beta
but I cannot show it to us here
we have it because I am now
talking to you through the ipad
I use the ipad for the ipad for the
link to learn languages so let's
see what we have here for Arabi
this
s how it looks like not in the libra
y and I'm studying various thing
here in Ar
bic but I'm going to start with my goals
ok my st
tistics well you can see n
you can see you know that during
the week last week I have learned
500 new words that is to say that as
then you know that in the link there are
about four levels of point
of view words yes yes
to what extent are we comfortable with the
word we think we understood  the
meaning of the word
there are states 1234 well
above all once a word
reaches your four or more there is already a
word a known word and I try
every week to convert 500 words to
the 600
known state words
and in this way I can increase  the
number of words known up to 20
life now I am at 18 thousand
well this means that during the
two months of the months of October and
November
and I learn  I gave 404 thousand words
I intend to learn another two
thousand during this month
and I am going to show how I do this and
in the statistics we can see for
example the one from the suite last week
but
last month
2000 almost 2000 well
the  1980 well
and
the number of 2,726 links this
means that I have found so many
new words that I have looked for in the
dictionary and I have saved but I still
don't know is to say that as you know
we have to find the same word
many many times to truly
understand  the meaning of this word
how to use that etcetera
ok those are words that I have
saved and we can see if, for example, at the
time that I
started studying Arabic here to the link
we can see what
in the number of links that I have  created,
that is, the number of words that I
have saved
is 850 5000, it is a lot, it is a lot,
so this is because I am useful, we can
see, for example, the number of
words that I have read  do and 344 thousand
words
I have listened to 500 more than 513 hours well
that is to say that every time you read the
link I am going to save phrases in content in
some law election of a new one I am going to
save phrases and words so I have
this enormous amount and it is not possible
study 50 thousand words in a system
of flash cards inc and whatever because it
would be a huge job every day spent
only with my flash card like hours
of hours and without being able to study 50 thousand
words then I have the
following strategy that I am going now
I am going  to finally explain the strategy
that consists in that among the 50 thousand
words that I have saved and that I have
seen in other elections in other
contents there are a
certain amount of words that
I already know but have not yet
become known words,
although and  within this
fifty thousand words there are words that
I can convert into known words
to reach the level of 20 thousand
known words at the end of this month
ok well  we are going to see
if we are going to see what we have here I
wanted to show you can see this is that
to import well I am not going to say if
today to look for the links
and I need interesting content
that I have looked for in the
audio podcasts I know  it goes but to
convert transcription into text I
use this javascript it is very very
good I can rock recommend it is to create
as an
automatic automatic transcription service and here we have
all the three that I have converted into
texts and when I can import those
texts in the  link but when downloading in
the transcript there is the possibility of
putting this display times' temps this is
very important to be able to study those
things
now they have a sentence
and for when am I going to import those
transcripts to keep the times
terms it is very important to use the
import inbox  the function matters if
you are only going to import the lesson it is not valid because you are
not going to lose the one of the teamsters and
to be able to study this  in prayer in
moderation we
need to use the import function
this
now we are going to see
how I do
to tackle all the enormous number
of links that I
created accumulated 50,000 words well
I go to the vocabulary section
well in the vocabulary section I have
50 thousand 54 thousand  words saved ok I
can't study all those words and
especially not in flash sky sporting
needs a lot of time to work on
the fresh ones
I prefer to use
list although there is a list well first
thing I am going to convert this list so that it
is a huge list  41,000
41,000 words not here, well, how am I going to
do it? I'm going to use solters and I'm going to
define
a status of the words that I want to
study, well, and this one, well, in order
of the alphabet, well, in Arabic, I
don't know the order of  the characters
of the letters are nothing but but it
doesn't matter good to apply
now I have all the words all the
words
are from this 23
that is to say that between those  words there are
every time I go there to look for
words that I already know there are always
good and there are many pages because here
I go there are about 32 pages of words
of status 33 and normally I start
with 1 because this is ordered according to
the frequency of our  words in
within the texts that we have in lake
and I am going to
ok gates
for example this one I am going to put in
acquaintance known
although it was that it suits him and that way I am going
to convert words every day I want to
search for about 100 words that I know
but at  same time each day I am going to
create new new links within the
transcripts of the mp3s of the
high podcast it is
good
that this one is ordered according to the order
of the alphabet but I am going to change that to
do it according to the importance of then
according to the frequency  the duty and here
we have
the words status 3 according to the
frequency that makes the income for a
moment and this is super important super
useful you are where I can virtual
the list  of vocabulary
many users of the link ask me for help
on this page and so I would only
like to point out that it can be
filtered it is used by moody's and it is very
serious
yes exactly up here to this
indication no symbol to
filter it can be searched for example
and  it does not start with ending with a phrase that
contains
good according to milk the date of
creation of the link
can also be filtered with context
for example for me in Arabic verbs
are very difficult so I can
only search for verbs in my list of
words not them well good  search is
the montage of disasters is that you can
review things that have something to do
with each other so the verbs
can be expressions of time can be
expressions of emotion expressions of I
don't know
good about things that have to do with
politics with  economy with medicine
what you want the tags the tickets I
don't know how it exists in Spanish
but this is what each user
believes  that are useful for him or
her, although exactly why because
as he is showing hostility now that
there are so many words, so many links,
and you don't know how to practice all of them at the same time, so being
able to create your own stands and
use them like that is very useful and you  it will
help a lot on his way I know
why
we must save many words because we
need many words there are not many
because there are people who say with a thousand
words with 100 they want 5,000 words
they can communicate but it is not the truth
they can say very simple things  but
to be able to understand what the other is saying
to be able to enjoy movies from books
and everything we need a huge vocabulary
so we have to limit the list of
words that we are going to study to review
we cannot
study to review like fifty thousand
words but verbs
status  3
things, for example, in each language there are
connecting phrases, not
so in the end, it seems to me that I don't know
things like that, they are very useful in English,
for example
by the point and useful phrases that
we want to acquire the power to use
well you can put a tag and study
those things then instead of studying
50,000 words or phrases you can study
like 100 there is a greater possibility of
learning them ok well
what do you think
there are questions that we can  answer and
we have many questions so I am going to
leave iab spain
leave leaving and here is
the presentation if there are many questions
a little comment also about
the impression although you always give us
so thank you
and here we have some questions or
first to some  users of the link
sent emails before today
so I'm going to start with those we have
sergio really
I wonder as a premium user can I
create a Brazilian Portuguese course
within the platform he saw that the
Portuguese in link this portugal is not
totally like that  but he only opened
in the port that is portugal
apparently on the platform so
the mail he asked you  it is possible that a
user from brazil starts publishing
brazilian portuguese here for all
users of course it would be fantastic i
must say that most of the
content we have in the library
the portuguese library is version
like café brasil podcast from brazil and
other  a lot and we can also look for
Portuguese from Portugal for opportunities and
why we have this classification but
always and I also believe the half-
stories in Portuguese we have
both
Brazilian and Portuguese but
we always want to have more more content and there
are people there for example for me in the
Arabic in Persian there are no people who
make recordings that they talk about their
lives they talk with their friends they talk about the
history of their country they talk about the cuisine
of their country they speak in a very natural way
and recording with him with the portable one
that is  quite enough and
then they do the transcription and they
contribute to our libraries and it
would be welcome and I think that all the
members who are studying
portuguese because most of them want to
learn brazilian portuguese because in
addition no no because it is better because there are
too many people who live in brazil
in this part of the world that more people
who travel in brazil in europe is the
opposite perhaps that there is  more europeans
who wanted to beat portugal but of
course welcome thank you very much for
this is the generosity and thanks in
advance to sergio and I also wanted to
mention that we are going to improve the
frustration of the library as well
so that they can
search better in portuguese so
since it is from europe
and but now you can still use it,
you can enter the
word brazil in the link library
and you will see more content from brazil
specifically but it is not perfect
now here you can review it and we are going to
improve this too so that  it's
easier ok
kelly I also think he's from brazil
ask me or if he asks you how to
keep the enthusiasm  motivation
to learn a new language because there are
times when we get discouraged
yes
first for me it is very interesting that
our bashir friends understand almost
all Spanish which is very like we
can't speak Spanish in the rather
they understand well how to maintain
the enthusiasm
well it depends on the person
what is the initial motivation
if we have a little success for example
for me studying as a Turkish Arabic Christian
or whatever and if I have a little
success at the beginning this encourages me not
because now I understand something because before
I did not understand shaking hands so this
success is already a form of motivation
because when we are successful when
we do something a little difficult but
we succeed we are successful this is it is very
encouraging this is this it gives us a sense
of satisfaction that pushes us to seek to
work to continue  but
at the same time you have to look
for interesting things for me to inhale is to
learn more about the political and
economic situation  omics or the history of the middle
east and every time I'm listening
and reading those podcasts in Arabic jon I
'm not doing this because I want to
accumulate more words yes I want to clarify
more words but at the same time for
me it's interesting the same content is
interesting so
and  unfortunately there are no
movies on netflix in standard arabic they
are piano movies in
lebanon no but in other languages in spani
h ay del ay ay marka
ián and telenovelas for e
ample on netflix that can be impor
ed then this according to interest as it
says  when we start we start it's
the satisfaction of being able to say something
understand something but past a certain
point
we have to look for interesting things
music cooking travel some some
things that interest us to keep the
enthusiasm good
I agree thanks steve we have a
lot of questions
first at the beginning of the  stream and
james said let's talk about teaching and not
just learning and it's just  a comment
but I would like to pass it on to you because I think it
is interesting because there are obviously
many
language tutors but obviously the link
is a platform so that you can
more or less teach yourself
you could be a little serious I think
well I think the link is  a
platform that does a lot to help
teachers teach language tests
because there is already good content because
normally progress has to find
something to give to the content that
students must study but the link
already exists a lot of content that the
teacher  you can control what you
are doing the students are doing you can
control the level of activity
there you are that's why we have
statistics statistics for you
because it's motivating no but also a
teacher who has about 20 students 50
students you can see the level of activity
how many hours  he has listened how many hours
the law how many words he has read and everything
then is a is  a tool
that helps students in that of the
teachers the teachers later how to
use it in the class in the wave well
this depends on each teacher but for
me not well I don't know
personally I don't have the experience of
teaching in a class but  I think so,
for example if there is if the students
can choose content in three before
but they have to reach a certain
level of known words hours of
listening certain goals that the teacher
can give and also in the class you can
discuss each of  the contents they
have studied use the words they
have learned I think there are many
ways to use the link as a
tool that facilitates the teacher's work
thanks steve ok
oscar I ask you he
also said that he is participating in the
90-day challenge the link that comes  of
licit oscar and he asked me is it
necessary to use the sls system to
learn kanji or not
in principle I don't I don't like it
a lot of ss systems because there are as
many words as 50 to 20 thousand
words that I have to learn in
any language
but in the case of Chinese characters
in cinemas yes I think it is useful and
for the first 1000 characters why
is it  so difficult and that we have to
learn to forget to learn to
forget and a system to do that can
help it is not necessary and this depends on
the taste of each one but that is the
case not for 50,000 words as I
said but with 1000 characters
if I  I think it can be useful to
combine
the study of the characters with s n s and
at the same time you have to listen to it,
for example the link can help in
this case but all that depends on the
taste of each one there are people
who like to use that  Flash
is possible I do not say no in that it
is not good I only say what I
like to do and if we do things that
the negus like we will continue the
most important thing of the apprentice in
learning  of languages this passes the time
o continue and not leave exact
exact say a
question to each so it
is and t
is is a question that we want sever
l times but since we are doing
this in Spanish we can answe
it again aniol asks
s is it possible to learn a language in a
ay  self-taught
I think that steve has taught himself
most of his languages but yes I
do know that also with Arabic you a
e experiencing a bit of a dep
ty-type type and y
u have a tutor so how would you a
swer this question well self-
aught what do you want me to  he is
self-taught the language does not exist in
your head the language has to
enter the language from outside your head
so it is not self-taught it
takes advantage of resources it can be
content it can be explanations of
grammar that a teacher can give you
or you can search  yourself
then I go for it now he also
bought me books and I am going to read those books
it helps me a little not much
there are resources c  ike mini-stories
like podcasts, I think that the
student who knows in a classroom or
independently has to look for you, they have
to have a feeling of initiative,
I'm not going to look for content, I'm going to
look for explanations of grammar as
functional to see the verb  verbs
because if the teacher does not explain one
thing is that we are not curious to
know how these verbs work
with structure we are not going to learn
so everything starts with himself but
resources a teacher can be a
resource google search verbs
in arabic  there are a lot of resources
to help us but
we study it is a
personal initiative finally
what happens in the classroom that is the one with the
link or wherever you want it is a
personal thing and I always have tutors but
not for the tutors to explain to me how it
works  the language because little by little I
am getting used to the language yes from time
to time I have some questions
but not much because
although the p  teacher explains to me I am not going to
name a part remember I am not going to
remember no then you have to continue to
get used to the language and the tutor
for me is someone with whom I can
talk finally I speak in Turkish in
Arabic and print or in Greek and the tutor
sends me  a list of words
and sentences where there was difficulty and
I am going to study to import this many
times the tutor is going to record this list of
words and expressions sentences and I
am going to study it
then no it is
not he is not to obtain can he explain but
it is not necessary so self-teaching
is a word
I do not like a bit we do not study with others with
friends with tutors with resources with the
language the language is the teacher
I do not know if this is an explanation I
do not know if because the key the key with link
and  with all the ways fluency
in language is staying motivated and
how can you stay motivated obviously
by being interested in what you're
studying so and we all know you're  or
you have a lot of interest in the politics and
the beast' of each country
so and with your Arabic you are trying to be
able to understand these
audience podcast and
am
and also here we have a lot of people who
ask us about how to improve the
pronunciation and they are asking us  in,
for example, with French, but I
would also love to know what you did,
what you do, to improve your
pronunciation with art, well, a
totally good alphabet
[Applause]
I think it was good when I
studied French, for example, myself
and made particular efforts  to
improve my pronunciation because
listening imitating listening imitating
but after this it seems to me that
the brain becomes more flexible
it is not so difficult to imitate the probability
is that because the problem is that we do not
understand the pronunciation we have to
listen a lot and if we only have one
language  in the head that is the spanish
portuguese in english the japanese is more
difficult to understand see truly
understand  what the pronunciation is
really like and if you don't understand what the
pronunciation is really like yes no if you do
n't realize the sounds if you
don't understand the sounds it's very difficult to
pronounce that's why for me
I listen to it and above all  all focus on
the rhythm of the language because if you have
the rhythm if you can imitate the rhythm
of the language
other things the pronunciation of sounds
would be even easier the use
of words in a natural way will be
easier
then the rhythm the music of the language
it is very important
we know that in french it is more monotonous
the mexicans sing more than the
spaniards well each language has its
music and we have to
imitate this music to be able to pronounce it well
for example in the link
if you can study
the ministry to scale each sentence
has the original voice
you can listen to imitate listen to imitate
listen to imitate
and sentence and after a sentence a
paragraph to be able to imitate the rhythm of the
language and always
will have or would have difficult sounds it is
possible that he will never be able to pronounce
those those sounds perfectly but
in pronunciation it is not a question of
perfection but perfectly it is a
question of speaking
with confidence speaking that people
can understand that they understand and it is not
a question of  perfection and listening
speaking listening speaking if you
want to find out I know what you
are testing in the language little by little
it will improve
if I would also add when you are with me you
can record on your cell phone and
compare the recording to the audio that
we have in our  lessons in links and
that has helped me a lot
concertantes which is difficult good but I would say I would
say that good if you speak Spanish and
English it is easier for you to pronounce
in French someone who is your first
language good foreign foreign it will be
more difficult one thing and  second thing to
record and listen to your voice only after
six months because at the beginning it will not
pronounce you  bad and it's not worth
listening to this bad pronunciation better to
listen a lot a lot a lot so that the
rhythm of the music of the language enters
your head and after six months you can
start listening because you are going to
hear imitate in your head
and it gives you the  impression that he is
pronouncing well and little by little
this pronunciation is going to improve when you
speak to your child but after six
months you can start recording and comparing
but before that is my experience not
clear because reading and understanding are the
basis of what  what he always proposes
we propose here in the link is to start with
that foundation because it is not but
also listening helps production but at the
beginning it will be difficult it will be difficult to be
able to pronounce well
yes of course
ok
[Music]
and he told us that you sing 500 words
a day  how many new words
do you keep zambia i think they are the same you dont keep
500 all good new words if
this is for good is a little
yes that is a very good question
there are two c  bears
there are the links created that are
new words that I don't know that I am going to
find in a text and I am going to save
in my database it
is a good blue word in our
texts and it is going to change little by little in
yellow
and it goes  to change status but about they
are still links they are words I think
good links created words saved
because but known words are something
else known words are words
within these in my case 50,000
saved words are words that
finally I can say I know I
know it does not mean that  I can
use I don't want to say that in
a content
if this word appears this word I
am going to be able to make sense to me I
understand well
obviously within those words
that I am going to put in the data with
known
would also be words that the second
the next time that  I'm going to see this
word I don't know anymore well I'm going to
put it back until your two or three this
happens many times but this doesn't matter
no im  porta because the trend is a
progression from I don't know anything to more and
more and more known words and the
texts get more and more clear and with
less and less unknown words
thank you thank you for the explanation
although what else
and you already covered a bit of this  how to
make a transcription with the studios
there as you mention you use javi it's
serious
amen to import the transcription in a
link along with the true audio and also
I just wanted to add that there are
some ways to make a
transcription with a link for example if
you want to import a  youtube video with
the subtitles or a netflix episode
with the subtitles will import with the
transcript which will be the
subtitles within the reading of dell
inc
something else to add stay alone
that good yes we have this extension
fraud extension  because extender I
don't know how it says in Spanish well you have
this symbol up on your page and if
you're watching a youtube movie yes you
can  I can explain about this symbol and
this whole movie with the subtitles with the
video going to enter as a lesson in a link
divided into sentences it's very easy it
doesn't always work but more or less
but in the case of podcasts I'm going to
put the mp3 on
the page  from javi drive so that the happy
trailer is transcribed later I am going to
import this text with the teamsters
but I have to import the mp3
separately well then each
member of the user has
to do this
experience import experience and to
know how this process works  of
import in which perhaps
next time we can
demonstrate how we can
import texts with audio with mp3 because
in this case it is a manual import
then text and then search for the mp3
so that the mp3 also enters the
region
this does not  it is necessary in the case of youtube
where both enter automatically and it
is also worth noting that being able to
use this extension
import helps you study exactly what
you want to study without any excuse
not to enjoy what you are
studying
when from time to time I will read from
tweets in Ukrainian in Czech or words
that I am not studying but want to
study in the link I understand more  or less
but there are words that I don't know well
I open the page of a newspaper in the
Czech Republic anywhere and click click
like this I click on this symbol and
this article enters as a lesson but
without audio because it is a
newspaper article and no  it's not something with
perfect audio thanks and they want us with a few
more minutes
some more personal questions for
example fernanda they ask you what level
of fluency you have in the Russian language and
now you to do what is the best way
to learn it
good at the level of  fluency in Russian good
I understand almost everything
good I can communicate express myself more or
less I say what I want but there are
words that I have already forgotten
and I make more mistakes now  than before
but with a little more practice I can
improve it but every language we've
learned is something we have
and we can always visit
and improve ourselves and well meeting these
old friends again is always a
great pleasure but I can't spend my
time perfecting my  Russian and at the same
time study Arabic and Persian and
other languages so my level of use less
ell than Spanish but not much
or use how to learn it is like
ll languages a lot of listening a lot of reading in
he case of Russian there are many many resour
es audiobooks of  the
classics with texts without rights what you
can import in the link
as I wrote that I have published there are
so many resources and the audiobooks in
Russian are of fantastic quality it is
one of the countries with the best quantity
and quality of audiobooks
[Applause]
the problems  with the use are for me the
cases
and the verbs well you have to practice
from time to time study the rules
to forget them
and continue ha  blar hoping for the
best but it's difficult it's difficult I've
used text a lot in the case of
Russian but above all it's reading,
listening and speaking without being afraid
perfect
Diego asks which language he
considers most useful after English he
has one  opinion this depends on the
situation of each one so if you
are doing business in china
well chinese is very useful in latin america it
should be spanish but if you or
in europe after english
i am not german or french in eastern europe
well, it could be Russian, well, the Russian, the
Arabic, the Turkish, I don't know about the
situation, obviously English is
the most useful language, if a Japanese is going to
meet a Brazilian, they are going to speak in
English,
that is why it is by far the most useful language
useful but there are regional languages like stand
rd arabic that they speak in all count
ies they understand environment they speak endor
e their local version but they understand this
anguage turkish through central asia spani
h good  yes chinese maybe in asia
according to me i think the importance of
regional languages is going to grow exact
y and from my perspective when i read all t
e questions and comments about
asia steve it seems to me that somet
mes people pay too much attention to which
would be the most  more useful or
in measuring
how difficult it will be to learn this language
and they spend time deciding or creating their
strategy and it does not simply start with a
link and with languages you have to be inter
sted so say if you have a high inter
st in any language in any cultu
e so that they do not spend  time
deciding or entering what would be the
best because they are capturing the
time that they could apply to their path
towards acquiring that language in
exact agreement and also this question which is
the most difficult language is independent
of your motivation there are many many people
who want to learn the  Japanese causes
of anime not good Japanese seems to be
a difficult language but if you
want to learn Japanese this is  s
what matters is the motivation
that each one has not a level of difficulty
objectively no it is not this motivation
that gives itself exactly so we have
a few more questions but if they are
not very repetitive so I go it is to all
my mail  so that they can contact me and
we can continue answering their
questions and in the future we will also
have more livestream so they speak
in several languages also to grow in an
wering everyone and i
you have any advice or somet
ing else to say to the viewe
s no  I have advice I just say that it is
always a great pleasure for me to
participate in this type of meeting
in different languages because the world of la
guage learning is a very pleas
nt world we are all frien
s who want to learn languages and share our e
periences and  I'm
sure we're going to do this again
thank you very much and thanks to all of you
so you can write me
this at sign I imputed it as
I'm going to write it ac  á in the chats and you
can write to me and we will do this in
the future not too so continue towards
your goals thanks steve thanks
see you soon bye bye